[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory we really don't
get what the big deal is about me
wearing this red shirt today anyway
Star Trek despite the show's seemingly
idealistic utopian worldview there's
always been something that's bothered me
about it something darker hidden beneath
the surface of every Star Trek series
and film I've ever watched I've seen
pretty much them all the original series
the animated series next generation Deep
Space 9 Voyager Enterprise the motion
picture the Wrath of Khan Star Trek
generations the JJ Abrams reboot there
are so many what have I done with my
life how many hours have I spent I mean
Star Wars fans only have to watch seven
films Star Wars fans only have to watch
four films the Tricky's have to watch
six different series and 13 different
films my god no wonder I'm so pale my
life could have been so different I
could have had facial hair anyway at
first glance the crew of the enterprise
seems like a bunch of benevolent heroes
Kirk and his crew repeatedly saved the
universe from alien clouds angry lizard
people and even God himself the Trek
reboot series has continued this trend
with Kirk and his crew fending off
against alien terrorists genetically
altered terrorists and then um well
another round of terrorists throughout
all of these there's always been one
consistent problem that no one talks
about every mission every fight every
supposed victory is told only from the
Federation's point of view each episode
of Star Trek in every subsequent film
features Kirk or
some member of his crew speaking into a
star log Kevin's log captain's log
Captain's Log Captain's Log
USS Enterprise captain's personal log
and as a result every episode in film
comes from an inherently biased
perspective a story told to us by the
Federation itself so the question today
is is there a story here that they're
not telling us is the Federation truly
as benevolent as they claim to be in
order to truly evaluate the Federation
in the real nature of the mission we
need to take a step back and boldly go
where no youtube host has gone before to
objectively analyze the Star Trek
universe based purely on behaviors of
the characters and their surrounding
society all we have to do is start with
the Federation's mission statement which
is conveniently repeated throughout
everything Star Trek space the final
frontier
these are the voyages of the Starship
Enterprise your ongoing mission to
explore strange new worlds to seek out
new life and new civilizations
to boldly go where no one has gone
before
this mantra boils down to one simple
word exploration the Federation claims
this exploration is only for acquiring
knowledge and searching the cosmos but
take one look at history and you see a
very different story
exploration tends to occur with two
different goals in mind one to claim as
many resources as possible to benefit
the home Empire and two to spread that
home Empire indoctrinating others under
a single government and religion
practically every single past
exploration falls under these rules from
the expansion of the Roman Empire to
British imperialism to the very
foundation of the good ol US of A
Christopher Columbus in 1492 didn't sail
the ocean blue and discover America just
a chill meet some natives and spend a
few wampum on an I heart Plymouth Rock
coffee mug no sir he claimed the land
under European rule and forced
Catholicism on all the indigenous people
even the first explorations of space
were fueled by cold war fears after
Russia successfully launched Sputnik
America needed to establish a foothold
in space before the Russians did it and
started raining nukes down from a bomb
it wasn't for education or discoveries
to maintain dominance that's only two
examples historically exploration has
always sprouted from primal and selfish
human needs and speaking to point one of
those two points we already know for
certain that the Federation is on the
hunt for resources there are multiple
episodes throughout the original series
like the empath and Fridays child where
we see the Federation's mining colonies
as well as them competing with the
Klingons for mining rights then what
about point to spreading the Empire why
would we think that the Federation is
any difference because they tell us but
if you look beyond Star Trek beyond if
you look Star Trek beyond their words
and start to see their actions you see a
completely different story a story of
fascism now just so we're all on the
same page fascism is a system of
government that controls all aspects of
a citizens daily life often it comes
neatly packaged with your friendly
neighborhood dictator some of the most
famous fascist dictators in history
include Hitler and Mussolini
world war two you know how well things
worked out there but then how is the
Federation this seemingly do-gooder
organization fascist well let's first
take a look at what they control in the
Star Trek universe transportation check
just take a look at the vehicle lists of
the Star Trek verse they're all built by
the Federation the only non Federation
ships that we see throughout the series
are those that belong to enemy alien
species if you're gonna want to travel
the solar system well then you're gonna
have to talk to Big Daddy Federation to
get some permission or just hop aboard a
smuggler ship who's han Solo in you need
him the Federation also controls
communication and the flow of ideas
every communicator is owned and
controlled by the Federation you can
even clearly see the Federation's
insignia and scribed on each one screw
iOS versus Android your Federation or
nothing then by Star Trek The Next
Generation ships like the enterprise-d
possess advanced computer systems that
are capable not only of running most
basic ship functions but also of
monitoring communications and the
location of every crew member on board
and not only does the Federation control
the flow of communication but also its
content they own two of the most
prevalent news programs in the galaxy
the Federation News Network and the
Federation News Service how about the
justice and criminal court systems again
it's under the thumb of the Federation
and they use that power to cull the herd
using unilateral hearings to weed out
anyone who descends or is deemed is
unfit for instance in the episode
Galileo 7 we see Kirk directly disobey
the orders of his high Commodore in
order to save his crew something heavily
frowned on in Starfleet
The Grudge lives on at a few star dates
and episodes later in the episode
court-martial we see the Federation
actively trying to get Kirk to resign
and when you
is trying to kick him off the ship in
the first-ever general court-martial of
a Starfleet captain going so far as to
hire a prosecutor who had a past
personal relationship with him they're
making up the rules as they go along to
make sure that Kirk gets kicked off but
it's not just in the original series mr.
Kirk's failed mutiny in the 2009 Star
Trek movie there's no trial no
deliberation no jury box simply orders
Kirk to be placed into a pod and
jettisoned off into an icy planets
justice here is determined solely by
those given power by the Federation and
what's more there are no checks or
balances to impede that power in into
darkness Admiral Marcus develops
long-range stealth torpedoes constructs
a secret mega warship and organize a war
mongering plot against the Klingons
those are feats Admiral Marcus did
single-handedly he was acting through
section 31 Starfleet black ops something
that required Federation funds and
personnel to accomplish sure Captain
Kirk and the crew saw his actions is
wrong and chose to fight against him but
then what about the rest of the
Federation where were they in all of
this additionally in order to maintain
control
fascists oppose any system in which
citizens have power as such they despise
capitalism which is designed to give the
common man Democratic power through
their spending in fact Hitler was
determined to quote destroy this system
under all conditions you know the old
saying Mo Money mo problems no money
dictatorial rule now think back to all
the times you've seen somebody in the
Star Trek universe by something or
exchange money I mean there are tons of
scenes of Kirk drinking at the bar but
you never see in pay and that's because
the Federation has done away with money
and Commerce in Star Trek first contact
we're told you see money doesn't exist
in the transaction
sure some purists might say that there's
an economic system in place revolving
around credits but look closer and you
see that this is only used as a form of
exchange with alien creatures who don't
understand the concept of economy
without currency it's a means to an end
the Federation in the territories that
it controls has done something that
Hitler could only dream of eliminate cap
ilysm you might be saying that this is
all meant to create a utopian society
that mankind is working to create a
universe beyond all wants and needs but
obviously they're not former members of
the federation routinely go rogue and
attempt to assert their own dominance
over civilizations in Star Trek beyond
the villain crawl is revealed to be
Balthazar Edison a disgruntled ex
Federation captain in star trek into
darkness Admiral Marcus another
Federation member attempts to start a
war between the Federation and the
Klingons all to further his own
political reach in power no matter what
the Federation may claim humanity is
still governed by the same selfish basic
motivations it's always been utopia I
don't think so even the ideology of the
Federation directly mirrors fascism
fascists emphasize the importance of the
state over the individual per Adolf
Hitler quote society's needs come before
the individuals sound familiar that's
right one of the most famous lines and
Star Trek history promotes fascism it
doesn't stop there
Star Trek is littered with offhand
comments by our suppose that heroes
endorsing the ideology in Star Trek
beyond Scotty tries to convince Jayla to
join Starfleet by invoking the famous
bundle of sticks proverb a single stick
breaks easily but a bundle of sticks is
unbreakable
harmless enough right except this simple
phrase is the very root of fascist
ideology in fact the word fascism
actually derives from the Latin fasces
which translates to a bundle of sticks
in fact the original symbol of fascism
in Italy was yet this a bundle of sticks
mind-blown oh yeah and what happens when
you dare speak out against the
Federation if you even so much as
question their motivations just look at
Star Trek beyond scroll he claims that
after voicing his displeasure with the
Federation he and his crew were then
stranded on the dying planet now you may
think to yourself why trust the word of
a Star Trek villain can we really
believe
his words over the Federation no way
right except we've already seen the
Federation do exactly what crawl claims
when Kirk dares to speak out against
Spock he's immediately exiled to an
inhospitable planet and very clearly
this is what the creators of the movie
had in mind just look at what they say
in this featurette of the character of
crawl I wanted a character that is there
to deconstruct the Federation's ideals
but to do it in a way where he has a
very valid philosophy well then just
what is the Federation up to in the
words of Spock an ancestor of mine
maintained that if you eliminate the
impossible whatever remains however
improbable and it's simply impossible
that the Federation a fascist
organization that controls every aspect
of its citizens lives that X tiles
anybody who dares question them would
explore the galaxies for purely
benevolent purposes their mission
statement then must be a lie a facade as
we saw in world war two fascists gain
power through fear building up anxieties
and citizens against other groups or
nations the classic example here is
Hitler and his crusade against people of
Jewish descent but now think about how
the Federation always paints their enemy
as aggressors or wrongdoers with the
Klingons Romulans and Cardassians
sorry Cardassians it's actually less
scary if we talk about them they all
could just be responding appropriately
to a fascist regime pushing across the
galaxy remember Star Trek is told
through the eyes of the Federation but
you should always question the motives
of the person telling you the facts so
that you can get what's really going on
both in fiction and in real life but hey
that's just a theory of film theory and
cuts so now that we've talked about Star
Trek let's talk about Starbucks
double-shot sponsor today's video but
not in the way that you'd expect the
Starbucks double-shot YouTube channel
just started a really cool new series
called uploaded where they're going
around to do some awesome mini
documentaries on all your favorite
YouTube channels it's kind of like
behind the music but behind the videos
and of everyone online I was one of the
first people that they wanted to work
with which is really flattering so if
you want to see some embarrassing old
videos of me some
awkward moments with me in the host in
the old recording closet or just a
little bit about what a damn the life of
a theorist looks like well then click
right here seriously it'd be awesome if
you showed them some support because at
a time when a lot of people still look
down and what we do online the fact that
Starbucks is dedicating all the time and
resources it takes to do little features
on us is really cool I kid you not they
brought a 20-person team to our house
for an entire day to do this thing it
was crazy I mean maybe a little bit of
overkill but it was still really
impressive by doing this series they're
showing us creators and the online
community as a whole a lot of respect so
click the annotation you see on screen
or the one in the description and check
out the video and leave them some love
in the comments tell them that you
really appreciate them doing this so now
that you've watched my video and you've
watched their video presumably that's
all I got for today next week something
a bit scarier I'll see you then if you
dare